alors mike ya un truc voilà on se
rappelle tous c'est avec l'histoire de
l'oreille est ce qu'on a vu mike tyson
rendre son oreille à evander holyfield
lorsqu'à tué par un héritier regardez
regardez regardez que la plupart
en soirée 20h
[Musique]
oui
est ce que est ce que je sais que dans
la boxe il ya beaucoup de shows est ce
que vous entendez bien avec evander
holyfield parce que c'était un grand
champion aussi on sait tous ce qui s'est
passé on faisait ses potes mais vraiment
super pote vous aimez beaucoup en fait
vous avez tourné ce petit sketch ensuite
c'était c'était c'était vraiment votre
pote même après tout ce qui s'est passé
9 non ben oui alors est ce qu'on a vu
mike tyson mettre un coup de poing et
gilles verdez quand il va livrer une
pizza
alors elle aurait tué est ce qu'on a vu
mike tyson participer à danse avec les
stars en argentine vous avez fait danse
avec les stars
you dance arrière est pas mal je pense
pas que les one two dancers ou non le
droit d'être suivi non non non non dans
ce
ceux-là
[Musique]
malheureusement j'étais là
tu regardes et papa dans danse avec les
stars ou pas les fléaux qui dansait bien
la femme qui danse avec moi c'est sa
mère non fort bien mais tu danses bien
mais qu'un j'ai essayé j'essaye baba
j'ai fait un concours donnant je vais
t'appeler je fais peut être une bombe ce
week-end à ta place tu as mal au dos l'a
ude a fait un peu mal au dos un petit
peu un petit peu et tu me lis sinon tu
passes au cabinet chien m'occuper de toi
est ce qu'on a vu mike tyson accueillir
chaleureusement un adversaire avec une
accolade et même un bisou ou la non
assurent non non non non là on l'a pas
dsk aurait vu mike tyson remporté un
combat de catch fait du catch up in my
time et le catch ou pas meridor j'adore
ça adoré regarder
regardez vous dit
à 8 ans il a le rire il a entonné la
couleur et cette couleur là
c'est la couleur qui fait rire
ah ok droite
[Applaudissements]
newly catch refaire oui si on m'appelle
pour faire du catch dirais tu sais que
j'ai eu un garçon téléphone qui est un
ami qui m'a dit tu ne te laisse un petit
message c'est tony yoka ce que tu
connais tony yoka le champion français
non tu connais pas non je le connais pas
eh ben il m'a dit voilà qu'il était kate
était pour lui le plus grand boxeur de
tous les temps voilà c'est tony aux
castes et champion olympique c'est un
des champions français et qu'il faisait
un gros bisou et était pour lui le plus
grand champion qu'il est connu en boxe
on a beau être finie cela et vous tu
fais de l'hoverboard un peu de
l'hoverboard il fait de l'hoverboard
papa non non mais c'est apparemment non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu à descendre tu avais dix mille à
ne pas en faire tu l'avais dit